So we have observed that when
the cache that we use as the L2 cache is
used alone, it has a higher hit rate.
Let's look back at our example.
Here, where we see that 128kB cache,
when used alone,
will have a relatively high hit rate.
But when we use it after the level
1 cache has already been accessed,
it only gets a 75% hit rate.
So it looks like the L2
cache has a lower
hit rate than the L1 cache,
which can be misleading.
So this particular type of hit rate we
call local hit rate for this cache.
A local hit rate is a hit rate
that the cache actually observes.
Of all the accesses to that cache,
this many are hits.
But note that all the accesses
to a level 2, level 3,
etc., cache, are not all the accesses
that the processor makes.
Those accesses that have a lot of
locality get to be all one hit,
and never reach these caches.
So, somehow,
their local hit rate is lower
because they never see
the easy accesses.
If such a cache was alone, it would see
this, which we call a global hit rate.
Essentially if we care only about how
many accesses that the processor make
go beyond a level 2 cache,
then we would really be seeing this.
But note that this hit rate really
includes the hit rate of the level
1 cache and what are the actual
hits in the level 2 cache.
So when we talk about the cache size and
how bigger caches behave better and
so on as far as hit rate is concerned,
usually,
we think about the global hit rate,
because the local hit rate
heavily depends on what do you
have as the level 1 cache.
If it's a level 3 cache then its
local hit rate would depend on what
is the level 1 hit rate,
what is the level 2 hit rate, and
only then we even get to
access the level 3 cache.
Its global hit rate is
going to be similar
to our hit rate of that type of
a cache if it was used alone.